and went welcome to this little video
playing the flap turn with black don't
have a clear memory and contact play
played against a min early games oops
oops yes we should you boys right I
think but this is this is a line that I
keep forgetting really what what is
correct and what's not it's a little
offbeat not it's not bad for a wide and
I tend to forget what is correct down
don't know if this is already maybe a
little bit of what i'm doing i would
like to go i should have played Bishop
e6 may be immediately yeah maybe
yeah it seems tonight you for so what
she wants to do so maybe I can try to
trade this wow that's not what I
expected latini allows me to take him
okay it's the rukon a2 is not not
terrible i mean nd5 is kind of weak so i
don't know what i really want to take
them the night coming to d5 is kind of
annoying and also that opening of the FR
k ithaca keep it keep this closed
hmm not to move i was thinking about
what okay i mean he he cannot take it on
c6 doesn't need anything so maybe just
specialty truth maybe just wants to play
normal developing move no goes back
uh-huh yeah i don't know what i want to
play a 5x looks somewhat wrong
[Music]
gee I'm taking us probably a little bit
one-sided but i'm still extremely solid
so let's say I take here and 95 I don't
think he wants to trade and if it is not
trade might be three as possible a 10
not sure if it really does all that much
okay I can take the beef farm and then
see later what's going on 95 I might
have see folsom what's this what is this
doing I go he and I were taking a
forward Italy not merely immediately as
he's got Bishop c5 it might be three and
then taking I definitely have on the
cards should be three is a little bit
unclear to me if this is a good idea
hmm yeah he's seeing some time I'm down
on the down on toilet catching up
written video seems kind of Statuary a
little bit strange so here
maybe I just tackle them maybe 3 i'm not
sure it could be lots of self pins
dumping on the beaver definitely cannot
be wrong now some of the video is
Statuary and i know i mean it's not
super important but don't quite know why
shouldn't be I have absolutely no other
applications on what something that
could drop down performance
so here what's going on here here that
was the plan
[Music]
I wonder if just knight c6 37 is good
trading no he wants to do you sharpen
the down ok I'm going to take the
material here it was clear that you
would sacrifice now least I expected it
that's that same let's say it like that
so we are king cakes Chase is also of
course fine so is he threatening
something here there is a check ok
doesn't do that much so let's grab the
Jeep on that could be a danger anyway
yeah I think Ruby a droopy one is my
plan trying to trade one pay looks check
night at five mm yeah that's a little
bit time morning irritating
yeah g3 nice cy wants to put the Queen
I would like to get a screen away from
that diagonal it I don't exactly know
how I can [ __ ] Callie and go Quinn here
for the for Queen age one not sure that
that this is actually that threatening I
didn't even see that you can trade winds
uh-huh I could have been easily a
blunder check check check check draw
chalford game drawn yeah i know i should
have won somehow oh good yeah it was no
long time and i will looked a couple of
things which made me not more didn't
raise the confidence level I'm so too
tough position yeah this a Forza is a
sideline that I looked at ages ago I
think this is probably sunlight only 95
and before business all so much ha don't
ask me this mean i mean this this cannot
be totally bad but I don't
really know if it's the best way to play
[Music]
so I think probably equality was was
somewhat equal so i'll try the same and
i was surprised about i don't think that
white can play one advantage like that
the engine gives equal yeah he could
have taken with the pawn of horses this
would have been interesting
strategically giving him the d5 square i
wouldn't try to be aight i took k in the
knight on d5 i can always try to
exchange it and don't think
automatically that whites bishop is
great i mean my bishop doesn't look good
but his bishop isn't this is much better
so I think this is this is roughly equal
young tier avoided the trade and now i
got this be foul play maybe I could have
played might be three I wasn't really
wasn't really all that sure does this
felt like some some self painting
business that I didn't like and I think
this is fine what I did I think yeah
okay this doesn't work at all but I
didn't didn't refute it to completely
check yeah I'm okay with that and now I
probably probably can improve oak-aged
to be 70 home check actually here I
didn't see that this is a queen try
funny enough i'm not sure if i would
have gone for it then because I mean the
ending is winning from like what the
time as a problem yeah the way it turned
out our roof system was actually lot
easier yeah I strived for 12
chatting Asian simply then then you can
play you can play with her check check
the close of the time is that is most
important thing and our position is a
dental ID he took the draw even though
it was four seconds up okay Gaza dad
girls call this game thanks for watching